[Music]
hi rob this is gail from missouri kansas
georgia and nebraska those are all
places that i've lived raised a family
and
made lifelong friends so when i go on a
road trip to one of those destinations i
uh literally listen to your podcast like
i've been doing all day today and it got
me wondering when was the last time you
went on a road trip and where did you go
thank you so much for your fun and
interesting conversations they really
help make the miles go by quickly
bye-bye gail
thank you for that okay sometimes the
universe talks to you
in unexpected ways
you
have convinced me i need to go on a road
trip it's something i've been thinking
about for a long time because i haven't
done one in in a long time like i did
when i was a kid and there's such a big
part of my
my memories i i don't know if they have
stuckey's anymore out on the road but
that used to be the best 25 miles to
stuckey's 15 miles to stuckey's five
miles to stuckey's and then you go in
there and they they sold all that crap
that was just amazing trinkets and then
and that what were the pecan rolls i
think they had
um
right stucky's pecan rolls let's go i'm
dating myself anyway
um yeah i would i my favorite one i
probably did when i was a kid and we
drove from dayton ohio in our vw van
and we went all through uh the black
hills of south dakota saw mount rushmore
yellowstone
and then all the way back to ohio it's a
lot of time in the car
my memories of it were you know this is
no smart phones no tablets i had a book
and my imagination and
i look back on that and i feel so
sorry for kids today
i really do it's like okay yeah they can
watch you know frozen for the billionth
time
but
they're not using their imagination
they're not dealing with how to deal
with boredom
and not to go totally far astray but i
think the biggest thing
in raising kids today and having kids is
their lack of ability to sit alone and
deal with
boredom we had to
and boy do you have to do that on a road
trip i did also want to rent a winnebago
the first year i was on the west wing
and i
damaged it right away getting out of the
driveway
and then
ripped the bicycles off the back
going over that famous bridge that you
see in all the car commercials
up at big sur but it was so fun there's
something about it i'm just saying
you're so on it there's something about
a road trip way better than some fancy
trip on a plane so thank you for
inspiring me i'm going to hit the road
trip and i think it's going to be
through the deep south
that's where that's where i want to go
next thanks for calling
you